Дякую дуже Шановний пане голову я
попрошу дві хвилини щоб далі потім час
не забирати будь ласка
знайти поправка номер
три і чотири і якщо можна Дякую Шановні
колеги Насправді Я навіть не закликаю
вас бити ці поправки тому що вони можуть
залишитись в цьому законі але мова йде
про інше Я хочу скористатись цією
можливістю ми зараз розглядаємо закон
про Службу безпеки України коли ми його
розглядали в першому читанні я казав
питання майна - це все дуже цікаво Я не
розумію проблеми які сьогодні є в СБУ з
майном яке 30 років ми СБУ майном
користувалися однак сьогодні є величезні
проблеми і ми дуже хотіли би почути
все-таки відповіді тому що є офіцери СБУ
які сьогодні боронять державу які На
жаль гинуть сьогодні на цій війні і це
наші герої і ми величезну повагу маємо і
Дякуємо але є на жаль зрадники в СБУ ми
бачимо справу Генерала Наумова який
тікав з діамантами ми бачимо справи про
СБУ представниках працівниках
херсонського управління центрального
апарату ми всі пам'ятаємо що 17 липня
друзі 17 до липня тобто декілька місяців
тому Іван баканов був відсторонений від
своєї посади голови СБУ указом
Президента Зеленського сформулюванням за
порушення статті 47-ї дисциплінарного
статуту збройних сил а саме невиконання
неналежне виконання службових обов'язків
яке призвело до людських жертв чи інших
тяжких наслідків Друзі Ну це таке
формулювання по якому ми маємо почути
відповідь А що ж зробив чи не зробив
Іван баканов однак З того дня ми нічого
не знаємо Іван баканов просто кудись
зник яка мене пішов на дно якесь на
якому дні Він знаходиться що
відбувається що показала перевірка це не
просто питання до баканова тому що це і
є єдине що нас забезпечить щоб це не
повторилось в майбутньому в цьому
зацікавлені Ми всі з вами тут бо від
роботи СБУ залежить життя кожного
українця сьогодні
тож ми вимагаємо і хочемо